bonjour nous sommes en direct
aujourd'hui pour vous faire un nouveau
point de situation sur ce qui se passe
en Ukraine on va le faire avec les
cartes du service infographique on va
vous montrer tout au long de ce live et
bien sûr je suis avec Alexis faire
chaque bonjour Alexis merci
je vous rappelle directement et adjoint
au pôle actuel excusez-moi déjà je me
trompe sur votre poste ça commence très
mal ce direct adjoint au pôle actuel du
Figaro voilà tout au long de ce live les
internautes vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr
à poser vos questions on y répond c'est
le but de ce genre de live on va vous
montrer les cartes que nous qu'on qu'on
fait le service infographies et on va
tout essayer de vous expliquer avant
peut-être peut-être une contre-offensive
imminente on en discutera justement
Alexis d'abord on peut commencer par un
petit point général en général de
situation ce conflit qui n'a pas
beaucoup bougé en termes de gains
territoriaux d'un côté ou de l'autre ah
non la carte vous la connaissez c'est
quasiment la la même depuis des mois
cette
plateforme un peu en
tranches le long de la mer d'Azov depuis
la Crimée jusqu'au jusqu'au Dombasle
l'allure générale n'a pas changé en
vérité aujourd'hui il y a il y a un
point de fixation c'est backmouth on va
le voir avec deux mouvements circulaires
les russes continuent d'avancer à
l'intérieur de la ville de bakhout et de
ce point de vue là ils ont pris un peu
plus de 90% de la ville peut-être entre
90 et 95 et de l'autre il y a les
Ukrainiens qui contre-attaquent on va
dire sur les flancs du dispositif russe
autour de backmouth ils ont gagné
quelques kilomètres carrés au nord et au
sud de la ville donc il y a ces deux
mouvements là en revanche il y a une
certitude c'est que la contre-offensive
ukrainienne n'a pas commencé il y a pas
de grandes manœuvre à un endroit du du
front ce front de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres on en reparlera mais on
attend toujours la contre-offensive on
sait pas du tout pour l'instant et c'est
normal enfin pas de communiquer de
presse qui qui
vont attaquer quand etc
donc on ne sait pas c'est peut-être dans
quelques jours c'est peut-être dans
quelques semaines
voilà et même la forme et la nature de
la contre-offensive pour l'instant on
sait trop rien même si on peut faire des
hypothèses et on parlera de ces
différents scénarios de de
contre-offensive on va commencer par
parler de la ville de de backmouth
puisque c'est là que joue ce conflit en
ce moment au début
Prigogine a des charis ce matin la ville
de bac Moon allait n'allait pas tomber
dans les prochains jours et que les
Ukrainiens ils ont annoncé aussi des
réussit autour de bac mood est-ce que
vous nous expliquer un peu ce qui se
passe autour de cette ville bon déjà il
faut prendre avec beaucoup de pain de
pincettes tout ce que dit prégogène
parce que pour le coup lui est un
excellent conseiller en communication
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler qui est prigo
j'ai une pardon trigogine c'est donc le
le
le chef de la milice Wagner c'est un
ancien cuisinier de Vladimir Poutine
c'est un homme
un homme de Londres mais qui est devenu
un homme public une personnalité
publique et qui a un agenda à la fois
politique à la fois économique et
financier parce que son rôle aussi son
objectif à lui c'est aussi de gagner de
l'argent c'est quand même un chef
mercenaire et puis évidemment on a un
agenda militaire puisque finalement ce
qui est complètement fou c'est une
organisation à l'origine de mercenaria
mais qui était pas dimensionné pour pour
affronter pendant des mois des mois une
guerre de haute intensité va se retrouve
à jouer un rôle pour lequel elle n'a pas
été pensée à l'origine la bataille de
bakbout c'est tout petit sur la carte on
aura parlera tout à l'heure en parlant
de l'ordre de bataille des deux côtés
c'est une bataille d'une très grande
envergure et qui dure au moins depuis le
mois dernier donc si Wagner à l'origine
n'a pas été pensé pour ça oui et puis la
ville en état elle pourrait tomber côté
russe mais à quel prix la ville est
absolument oui là il est quand même
probable que là que la ville tombe dans
les tombes dans les prochains jours en
fait ce qui se passe là on le voit sur
la sur la sur la carte d'ailleurs là sur
la carte on voit à peine que les si on
prend la partie vraiment la zone urbaine
là on voit les le quadrillage des rues
donc on voit bien les limites de la de
la partie urbaine de la de la ville on
voit à peine que les Ukrainiens tiennent
encore un tout petit bout de la ville
pour être très très précis c'est à
l'ouest de la ville c'est la partie en
jaune et en fait à cet endroit là il y a
il y a un point de fixation
parce que il y a une zone avec des très
grands immeubles très haut très très
très lourd avec du beaucoup de béton
et c'est là que sont retranchés les les
Ukrainiens en fait ce qui est très
intéressant et là pardon d'être dézoomer
de nouveau c'est c'est la stratégie
russe pour prendre backmouth
au début c'est à dire quand je dis au
début c'est la partie on va dire de
l'automne 2023 les rues sont tenté une
manœuvre d'enveloppement et
d'encerclement de backmouth au début ils
avaient pas l'intérieur de la ville ils
étaient à l'Est ils ont essayé de passer
au nord et au sud et on le voit parce
que finalement le dispositif russe va
assez vers l'ouest oui et donc l'idée
c'était de prendre d'envelopper la ville
pour éviter
une guérilla
urbaine à l'intérieur de la ville parce
qu'on sait que les combats urbains sont
particulièrement meurtriers et notamment
pour pour la saillant sauf que ça c'est
pas la première fois qu'on le voit dans
la guerre Ukraine la manœuvre russe dans
cerclement de backmouth n'a pas
fonctionné parce que très vite en
réalité les Russes se sont arrêtés il y
a un moment ils ont quasiment réussi à
couper les deux grandes routes
ukrainiennes qui vont vers la ville
alors l'idée c'est évidemment de couper
la log et donc les soldats Ukrainiens
auraient été coincés à l'intérieur de la
ville
c'est vraiment tendu il y a plusieurs
enfin plus maintenant mais à un moment
il y avait plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de de soldats
Ukrainiens dans backmouth et autour de
makmouth c'est vraiment là où toutes les
forces sont centrées mais cette
stratégie d'encercle morue n'a pas
fonctionné les les Ukrainiens ont réussi
à rouvrir ces deux grandes routes qui
vont vers une autre ville pas très loin
20 30 km qui est chassifiant et c'est
vraiment le le
l'arrière du fond ukrainien les centres
de contrôle etc sont à châssis fier
c'est donc les les Russes n'ont pas
réussi leur manœuvre dans cerclement ils
ont compris assez rapidement que c'était
pas possible et donc ils ont entamé une
manœuvre beaucoup plus classique de
combat urbain donc il fallait avancer
rue par rue numéro par minéraux mettent
par mètre et donc finalement depuis
trois mois c'est ça qu'on voit c'est
l'avancée des mercenaires de de backmoot
de l'Est vers l'Ouest et là on en est à
la toute fin c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
vraiment un énorme bloc d'immeubles très
haut qui reste et les Russes
avancent très lentement parce que parce
que c'est miné parce que on a vu que les
Ukrainiens ont fait sauter un certain
nombre d'immeubles donc les Russes eux
pourraient essayer de conserver ces
immeubles parce que après ça fait des
positions défensives qui sont qui sont
très utiles parce qu'il faut avoir
l'esprit qu'il y a cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui qui se
prépare
et donc voilà mais en parallèle de ça il
y a non pas une contre-offensive
ukrainienne c'est pas une grande
contre-offensive celle qu'on attendrait
dans les jours les semaines qui viennent
mais il y a il y a deux contre-attaques
à la fois par le nord et par le sud pour
casser dans la périphérie de
de backmouth justement
saillant les deux saillants russes au
nord et au sud et là il y a un point de
repère qui est important c'est qu'il
faut savoir que à l'ouest de batmouth
entre châssis fiards
au sud cette zone c'est le canal de
sévaski de Ness et les Russes avaient
réussi
au nord à atteindre le canal au sud même
réussi à le franchir et franchement ils
étaient pas loin du tout du sud de
châssifiards et aujourd'hui là en
quelques jours les les
Ukrainiens ont pris quelques plusieurs
kilomètres carrés et on repoussé les
rues ça je veux pas dire de bêtises mais
mais pour l'instant les les les
les Russes enfin il y a même une tête de
pont ukrainienne par dessus le canal
vers l'est à l'intérieur du dispositif
russe et donc là on le voit rapidement
il y a vous voyez la ville de Clichy
au nord-ouest de
pardon aussi sud-ouest de makmouth c'est
vraiment la ligne de fortification russe
et les Russes ont intérêts à tenir parce
que sinon on peut imaginer une manœuvre
d'enveloppement inverse c'est-à-dire
exactement l'inverse de ce qu'on voulut
faire les Russes sans y arriver et là si
les russes arrivent à prendre backmoon
mais qu'ensuite le dispositif au Nord
Est au sud s'effondre
finalement ça sera une victoire à la
Pyrrhus pour les pour les Russes même
au-delà de la question de savoir si
backmout avait un intérêt stratégique et
de savoir
si finalement la quantité d'hommes
perdus par les Russes et finalement
fallait le coup voilà alors on a pas mal
de pas mal de questions dark look qui
nous dit est-ce que c'est un piège
est-ce que ce piège se permettrait aux
Ukrainiens d'en finir avec Wagner en
Ukraine alors pour l'instant toutes les
troupes de Wagner en fait l'immense
majorité sont concentrés dans la zone de
bakmouth sachant qu'avec il n'y a pas
que Wagner dans le cœur de la ville
c'est grande majorité Wagner mais
justement le dispositif autour et pour
le coup l'armée russe et force russe
conventionnelle
mais ce qui est certain c'est que si les
Wagner perdaient un bac mood ça serait
une défaite cuisante à la fois politique
militaire et aussi
financière pour pour
très franchement on en est pas là on en
est vraiment pas là donc faut être
extrêmement prudent est-ce que je me
rappelle qu'il y a quelques semaines il
y a quelques
on imaginait que la manœuvre dans le
cercle morue avait l'air de fonctionner
les deux routes dont je vous parlais et
étaient coupés il y a un moment elles
avaient été prises voilà faut rester
très très prudent sur ce qui se passe
effectivement dans les commentaires on a
maquillé qui nous demande est-ce qu'on a
une estimation du nombre de soldats sur
place avec c'est très compliqué alors à
back même il semblerait qu'il reste plus
que 1000 ou 1000 soldats c'est à peu
près les ans de grandeur c'est très en
dessous il y a quelques mois ou dans
même vous pouvez imaginer qu'il y avait
10000 soldats il y a un chiffre parce
que j'ai des notes sur l'ordre de
bataille
ukrainien c'est assez intéressant les
Ukrainiens disposent d'environ une
centaine de brigades c'est l'ensemble
des forces
ukrainiennes opérationnelles une
centaine de brigades ça fait environ 300
000 hommes c'est à peu près 3 000 hommes
par brigade ce qui est très intéressant
et ça c'est Michel Goya qui en parle
dans un article récente de son blog
c'est qu'il y a 42 de ces brigades
qui sont non pas avec dans la région on
va dire backmoon Donia prêt à se
déplacer c'est absolument considérable
c'est à dire que dans cette zone qui
n'est finalement pas gigantesque grosso
modo c'est un carré de 150 km par 150 km
vous avez 120000
Ukrainiens on peut imaginer qu'il y a
peut-être un peu plus de russe mais mais
pas tellement plus l'ordre de bataille
russe les ordres de grandeurs sont les
mêmes on se souvient qu'il y a eu la
mobilisation
à l'automne et qui portait sur 300 000
hommes on peut imaginer évidemment que
les forces qui étaient là avant la avant
la la mobilisation mal non pas toute
disparu il y a l'origine il y avait 200
000 soldats après il y a la pression il
y a une vision des forces les Russes ont
perdu probablement 100 000 200000 hommes
vous voyez on est dans les mêmes
ordres de grandeur
grosso modo 300 000 lesquels comme des
deux côtés
et puis au moins un bon tiers ils sont
concentrés dans le dos bas c'est
notamment dans la région de Marco c'est
ça les ordres de grandeur voilà c'est
pour le centre de grandeur on a Napoléon
qui demande les pertes des deux armées
on a des estimations là aussi c'est
toujours des films très compliqués c'est
très compliqué les les il y a plein de
déclarations dans tous les sens des
Occidentaux des Russes des Ukrainiens
etc
c'est au moins 200 000 à 200 000 hommes
des deux côtés il y a probablement plus
de pertes du côté russe mais après des
chiffres exacts je m'avancerai pas en
tout cas moi je ne les ai pas ça on sera
pas du tout pour vous le dire d'ailleurs
vous pouvez retrouver c'est un article
un reportage de notre de notre envoyé
spécial sur place c'est Cyril oui vous
pouvez retrouver d'ailleurs cet article
sur le site du du sur le thème de la
chute imminent de darkmouth et sur le
fait que ça pourrait être une victoire à
la à la Pyrrhus parce que autour les
Ukrainiens ont des contre-attaques sur
les sur les flancs ça ressemble tout à
l'heure qui me disait ça ressemble à un
piège
oui alors après faut toujours
parfois on fait ce qu'on peut et c'est
pas toujours des gens planifiés général
Olivier Kempf imaginer aussi que les
Russes finalement n'avaient pas cherché
à
se fixer justement dans ces deux pinces
de la tenaille dans la mesure où elle ne
leur servait plus immédiatement
parfois on fait ce qu'on peut faire et
c'est pas forcément un grand choix
stratégique mais on peut imaginer
effectivement que les Ukrainiens tente
une manœuvre d'enveloppement de
darkmouth ça ça paraît tout à fait
crédible en tout cas comme volonté alors
on va parler un peu de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne une
contrepartie qui est dont on parle
maintenant depuis plusieurs mois qui
semble imminente on en parle qu'elle est
minante depuis un moment jusqu'à ce que
il y a deux semaines le président
voulait dire ce qui a dit
on presque prêt mais pas totalement ce
sera pas pour tout de suite en fait oui
et donc en fait la communication de
guerre et c'est parfaitement normal
pour auchenko donc l'ancien président
ukrainien a accordé une interview au
Figaro dans lequel lui il dit que c'est
plus qu'une question de jours lui-même
dispose de sa propre ministre privée qui
sponsorise en Ukraine puisqu'à côté
défense régulières il y a il y a aussi
des des bataillons de de volontaires qui
forment un peu de des brigades
territoriales et en général c'est une
infanterie de l'infanterie légère
maintenant de tout est possible si elle
se trouve on va observer la la
contre-offensive dans les jours qui
viennent peut-être que ça sera dans
quelques semaines
il faut en fait il faut comprendre les
enjeux le leur et l'heure et le jour ça
ne n'est pas tellement la question
conseil arrivera on en parlera
quels sont les enjeux finalement
c'est que on le répète à longueur de
live mais le front finalement est figé
depuis des mois et des mois et des mois
et donc si vous voulez les il y avait eu
ces contre-offensives ukrainiennes de
l'automne et là on le voit très bien
c'est les zones libérées en bleu au nord
du front et aussi du front dans la
région de quartier et dans la région de
Kerson et notamment les
Ukrainiens ont repris la ville de Kerson
parce que les Russes sont retirés de
replier de l'autre côté du Nièvre donc
elle laisse d'une Nièvre depuis la
situation est figée les rues savaient
annoncé une offensive on va dire divers
on voit très bien que c'était
réellement une véritable offensive ils
ont grignoter quelques dizaines de
kilomètres carrés ça s'est réduit
principalement à la bataille de
darkmouth mais l'allure générale de la
carte
et la même depuis des mois il n'y a pas
réellement de grande manoeuvre et donc
si la contre-offensive ukrainienne
n'a pas de portée stratégique qui n'a
qu'une portée tactique extrêmement
localisée
on va finir par se dire que cette guerre
est un conflit je l'ai ça pourrait donc
avoir dans les mois à venir en cas
d'échec de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne des implications sur
l'avenir de cette guerre et même sur la
la position des des occidentaux les
Occidentaux soutiennent massivement les
Ukrainiens donc il y a la possibilité
d'une victoire militaire
ukrainienne qui se traduisent sur le
terrain alors les politiques vont pas le
dire comme ça mais si j'aimais l'état de
fait était différent c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'acheminait vers une ligne de front
durablement figée on pourrait voir
l'automne prochain vraiment l'année
prochaine
un début de négociation et alors ça
c'est sorti dans la presse américaine il
y a eu un long article de politique et
un autre du final
très intéressant
pour les Ukrainiens cette
contre-offensive elle est absolument
primordiale parce que pour eux c'est
c'est la possibilité d'une victoire
militaire finalement qui qui se pose et
donc ils ont besoin d'une victoire
stratégique les deux contre-offensives
dont on a parlé précédemment celle de
car kiffe et celle de Carson n'ont pas
eu de porter stratégique ça a été une
humiliation
pour la Russie ça c'est une certitude
mais elle n'avait pas de portée
stratégique parce que la tête de pont
russe de l'autre côté du Nièvre c'est
vers l'ouest n'avait aucun sens sinon
pour le pour le symbole politique de la
ville de Carson une tête de ça sert à
aller plus loin défendre une tête de
pont pour défendre une tête de pont ça a
très peu d'intérêt et près de carquif et
une vaste zone où il y avait quasiment
pas de de zone urbaines par la ville de
Campion donc voilà ça n'allait pas grand
grand intérêt là les Ukrainiens ont
besoin d'une victoire militaire de
portée stratégique et là ça veut dire
quoi concrètement
il y a deux possibilités il y a soit
prolonger la contre-offensive qui était
à CARIF au nord peut-être en passant
plus le site pour enfoncer le dispositif
russe dans le don basse et où là on
imaginerait ni national un effondrement
du dispositif russe originel là où il y
avait eu la création des deux
républiques séparatistes du don-basse en
2014 donc ça c'est la première grande
hypothèse et la deuxième grande
hypothèse avec plusieurs variantes
une attaque plus au sud
qui coûterait cette ce corridorus parce
que c'est un peu la forme d'un corridor
russe pour couper la Crimée du Dombas et
donc là on peut imaginer là on le voit
bien sur c'est un des scénarios une
attaque par la région de la corridja qui
filait vers le sud pour s'emparer par
exemple d'un port comme berdionce ou la
ville de Milito Paul qui est le vrai le
hub logistique le le point de gravité
militaire
dans le dans le sud de l'Ukraine et
finalement après melithopole qu'est-ce
qu'il y a la Crimée mais sans aller
jusqu'à la Crimée parce que ça
l'ultime objective des Ukrainiens avant
ça il y a un objectif premier qui est de
couper le dispositif russe en deux et ça
c'est pas évident parce que
contrairement à au mois de au mois
d'octobre
2023 les Russes là ont compris qu'il
fallait arrêter la capacité de manœuvre
ukrainienne et donc ils se sont
fortifiés et ce qui est intéressant que
c'est pas une les quand on regarde
comment sont fait ces fortifications
alors c'est des sont des tranchées
des bunkers etc etc c'est pas une grande
ligne Maginot pour empêcher les
Ukrainiens d'avancer d'un kilomètre
c'est pas ça c'est une succession de
lignes de défense sur une centaine de
kilomètres pour finalement
freiner les ukrainiens et que s'ils
avancent ça soit un succès pourquoi pas
tactique les Russes pourraient le
supporter mais que ça ne se transforme
pas en victoire stratégique pour les
pour les Ukrainiens oui voilà il faut
pas il faut
l'idée c'est de parler trop vite trop
loin en fait c'est ça c'est d'arriver à
aller suffisamment les suffisamment les
les ralentir les agents que les
Occidentaux sont très prudents dans ce
qu'ils disent de de la la possibilité de
la contre-offensive
ukrainienne parce que on l'a vu les
le dispositif ukrainien n'est pas non
plus
que le sale en terme de de masse alors
ils ont tout un tas d'avantages
notamment en termes qualitatif parce
qu'ils ont reçu de nouvelles armes
occidentales notamment des chars des
blindés et puis on va le voir un certain
nombre de vecteurs pour jouer dans la
profondeur du dispositif russe tout ça
et bien vrai mais après en termes de
masse ils ont pas une capacité de
manœuvre absolument monumentale
on peut en parler d'ailleurs maintenant
je vous disais une centaine de de
brigades il y a une vingtaine de
brigades qui sont en formation dont on
peut imaginer certaines d'entre elles
dans dans les prochaines semaines ou
dans les prochains mois
seront disponibles mais si vous voulez
vous ne faites pas une grande
contre-offensive avec de l'infanterie
légère il y a une grande partie du
dispositif ukrainien notamment ce qu'on
appelle les brigades territoriales
d'environ une trentaine ce sont des
brigades territoriales c'est de
l'infanterie légère le cœur du
dispositif pour une grande
contre-offensive c'est les brigades
blindées et les brigades mécanisées dans
une moindre mesure les brigades
motorisées en gros derrière ces termes
c'est le degré d'équipement lourd Shark
de Charles depuis longtemps
des bataillons de chars appuyés par de
l'infanterie dans une mécanisée c'est
l'inverse et dans une dans une
motorisé c'est principalement de
l'infanterie et puis il y a juste
une unité de charme et beaucoup plus
petite donc les Ukrainiens par exemple
jusqu'à maintenant avec 4
brigades blindés c'est extrêmement peu
dans l'absolu il y en a deux autres en
formation on parle d'une de moins d'une
cinquième qui serait déjà déployée
quelque part autour de créviry donc
c'est pas très loin de la zone de front
en termes de brigade mécanisé ils en
auront
maintenant ou dans quelques semaines une
grosse vingtaine on voit que ce sont pas
des chiffres absolument le saut et si on
parle de char
ils ont reçu
aller entre 100 et 200 chars
occidentaux et même pas dans l'eau il y
a des T62 qui sont d'origine soviétique
ont été modernisés par les Polonais mais
mais le le cœur du dispositif
c'est-à-dire
les les chars allemands les ou par deux
pour l'instant s'ils en ont une grosse
centaine opérationnelles
c'est c'est vraiment le bout du monde on
est très loin d'une grande force
et puis ils ont toujours le problème si
ils peuvent difficilement mener une
contre-offensive avec un appui aérien
et ça réussit une contre-offensive sans
appui aérien c'est extrêmement compliqué
donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a aussi cette
prudence sur les résultats attendent de
cette contre-offensive après
complètement surprendre
l'adversaire et l'ennemirus et on peut
rendre compte que l'état de faiblesse de
l'armée russe c'est encore plus
important que ce qu'on attendait parce
qu'on voit qu'il y a une attrition du
matériel lourd du côté russe qui est
absolument considérable on est là je
crois que ça y est on a dû franchir les
2000 chars russes détruits et ça c'est
juste ce qu'on a pu voir observer
confirmer il y en a peut-être un tiers
en plus de 1000 chars c'est juste
absolument considérable et aujourd'hui
on voit arriver en Ukraine des T54 des
55 il y avait déjà des T62 le chiffre 54
55 62 ça se rapporte à l'année de
l'entrée en service donc on parle de
matériel
ça veut pas dire que c'est complètement
inutile ça peut servir à de
l'infanterie mais mais en tout cas il y
a un effet glissement du dispositif
russe qui est indéniable même si parfois
sur certains endroits certains endroits
une capacité de d'adaptation
on l'a vu avec les drones au début de la
guerre les Russes avaient un retard
absolument considérable notamment pour
les drones d'observation qui permettent
à l'artillerie d'être plus précise plus
rapide etc aujourd'hui le ciel ukrainien
est littéralement quadrillé de drones de
reconnaissance russe on voit aussi alors
c'est une autre forme de neurones les ce
qu'on appelle les drones suicides qui
sont des drones qu'on porte des petites
charges explosives qui vont pas très
loin dans la profondeur mais qui
permettent de cibler des pièces d'Ar des
chars etc et là
maintenant pas mal de moi et vidéo à
l'appui on voit que c'est des drones les
drones landset on voit que les Russes
ont acquis un savoir-faire qui n'avaient
pas au début de la guerre pareil la
l'aviation russe ces dernières semaines
ça c'est relativement nouveau
comment ça a utilisé un peu plus
intensivement des bombes téléguidées qui
permettent leur chasseur et il y a une
portée de 30 40
60 km donc les chasseurs n'ont pas à
rentrer trop profondément dans le
territoire ukrainien enfin dans le
territoire tenu par les Ukrainiens
pardon et pareil ils peuvent du coup
taper l'arrière du front de manière plus
précise aussi leurs avions ont des
bombes lisses à gravité et doivent
passer au-dessus de la cible la larguer
avec une précision extrêmement mauvaise
et un risque de se faire un bac très
élevé
voilà maintenant c'est
on peut pas prédire le résultat d'une
guerre je pense que tous les
commentateurs sur la guerre en Ukraine
se rendent compte depuis maintenant plus
plus d'un an donc prudence Sébastien
Clerc qui nous demande est-ce que les
est-ce que les USA vont toujours envoyer
des chars Abrahams
oui
ils sont absolument pas revenus sur sur
leur promesse mais attention on parlait
de 30 chats Abrahams et la plupart des
sources américaines alors c'était un
discours officiel mais enfin c'est sorti
dans tous les grands journaux américains
disaient qu'il n'y aurait pas d'envoi en
Ukraine avant la fin de l'année 2023
voir le début 2024 on a le temps de voir
venir le en fait il y a plusieurs
questions techniques les Américains ne
veulent pas se dessaisir de char de leur
propre armée et donc ils envisagent
d'utiliser des chars de réserve ou des
chars qui seraient dans des armes
étrangères de les
modernes restaurer tout simplement et
les envoyer sur le front donc ça prend
beaucoup de temps et après les charabes
en plus sont des chars qui sont
difficiles à utiliser donc il y aura
aussi des mois de formation donc
aujourd'hui la question n'est pas du
tout celle des chars Abrahams on l'a vu
le le point de finalement le point
commun le le
en matière de chat qui réunit à peu près
tous les pays européens ce sont les
âmes léovah les Léopards 2 allemands
parce qu'il y a une vingtaine de pays
quand sont équipés et que si on prend
tous les pays européens équipés d'amrans
on a stock de plus de 1700 léopards 2
plus de 2300 avec les Léopards 1 qui
sont beaucoup plus anciens et donc là on
peut
imaginer que les Européens se
dessaisissent de 10 15% de leur stock et
là ça donne un nombre de chars sérieux
pour que ça soit utile tout simplement à
l'Ukraine les les Britanniques ont été
parmi les premiers ont été les premiers
à annoncer des chars lourds les
challengers mais ils en ont dans un
premier temps annoncé 14 et monter à 28
l'intérêt opérationnel est quasiment nul
parce qu'il faut que vous créiez
en plus une chaîne logistique
régulière pour une vingtaine de chars
c'est quelques
deux ou trois compagnies ça ça
franchement un intérêt négligeable le
char c'est donc le léopard et on va en
parler aujourd'hui la question c'est les
avions oui alors justement j'ai une
question en plus j'ai une question en
plus sur les avions est-ce que
Christophe est-ce que c'est la ce sont
la quasi priorité absolue pour une
offensive sans avion c'est difficile lui
nous dit l'échec qui coûtera très cher à
l'Ukraine non mais ça c'est des propos
je suis désolé pour ce monsieur je
connais pas mais mais être aussi
affirmatif ça n'a aucun sens
voilà ça fait un an et demi que la
guerre en Ukraine nous l'apprend et
quand on lit un peu d'histoire militaire
ça fait des siècles donc non le fait que
la contre-offensive qui va arriver dans
les semaines ou dans les mois qui
viennent se fasse sans soutien aérien
évidemment que c'est une gageure pour
les ukrainiens et que ça va être très
compliqué
pour avoir qu'il y a d'autres moyens
pour les moyens de taper dans la
profondeur mais c'est sûr que c'est une
gageure en revanche pourquoi on ne peut
pas dire aujourd'hui que les F16 sont
une priorité c'est précisément parce que
il ne n'arriveront pas à temps
probablement probablement
pour
la contre-offensive si elle a lieu dans
les jeux où les semaines qui viennent
c'est que l'enjeu des F-16
c'est peut-être à l'automne prochain de
même que pour la contrepensive qui vient
là les enjeux l'enjeu c'était le léopard
et le léopard n'en a parlé quand on en a
parlé en avril
enfin en mars fait février mars dernier
le temps on peut pas si vous voulez le
là on en est aux discussions sur le sur
le F-16
c'est pas pour demain il y avait un
point préalable en revanche sur la
question des avions c'était les Mig29
que des pays européens c'est-à-dire des
avions fabrication
le d'ancien pays du bloc de l'Est en
Europe
pourrait livrer à l'Ukraine ce qui est
d'autant plus commode que les pilotes
Ukrainiens connaissent très bien ce
chasseur qui a un chasseur de 4e
génération des années du début des
années 80
et donc ça oui là pour le coup c'est
crédible les Polonais en ont et il y a
un autre pays qu'on a annoncé une
livraison mais je veux pas te dire de
bêtises peut-être le Vénus
dark look qui me dit en Ukraine qui nous
parle du terrain qui me dit que les sols
ne sont pas suffisamment asséchés il y a
aussi ça en question à prendre en compte
pour supporter le passage de dizaines de
véhicules blindés oui c'est un la métaux
est un enjeu alors tous les analystes
qui observent le conflit
regarde la météo chaque jour
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y a une
saison des pluies qui a duré
longtemps alors il y a eu plein de
théories
enfin moi j'ai absolument évident aucun
élément là-dessus mais les les
Russes en ont parlé beaucoup de
complotistes ont repris cette idée
d'armes d'armes climatiques c'est à dire
que les russes auraient fait pleuvoir
dans la dans la région de bac mouth
enfin évidemment du côté ukrainien pour
retarder la contre-offensive
ukrainienne soyons très clair il n'y a
absolument aucun élément tangible
on sait que c'est une chose que les
Russes savent il y a aucun précédent
militaire enfin d'emploi militaire a été
répertorié
voilà ce qui est clair c'est que là on
rentre
dans dans
la saison où l'offensive redevient
possible après la saison des bouts je le
rappelle et bien pire pour le pour la
capacité de manœuvre des troupes que
l'hiver que l'hiver le coeur de l'hiver
où les seuls sont gelés et donc dur et
donc les chars peuvent quand même passer
on a Dan qui nous demande si l'Ukraine
va recevoir un le d'homme de fer
un système intimité justement on voulait
en parler aussi c'est c'est les systèmes
antimissiles qui utilisent l'Ukraine
alors vaste sujet sur la question du
Dôme de fer
c'est donc le système bien connu
d'Israël
Israël si vous voulez c'est un tout
petit pays qui
reçoit on va dire très régulièrement des
roquettes tirées des territoires
palestiniens ou du sud du Liban et donc
ils sont devenus tout à fait maîtres
dans la défense aérienne à courte portée
pas tellement dans la défense aérienne à
très longue portée sur des centaines de
kilomètres là il y a des grands
spécialistes en théorie les Russes
américains qu'on le fameux système Engis
etc
les Israéliens ont vraiment ce dôme de
fer qui sort de bulles impénétrables
mais avec des interceptions qui font les
courses porter et donc pour les
Ukrainiens évidemment ça pourrait être
très
utile ce qu'il y a c'est qu'il y a une
sorte de
il y a d'ailleurs une interview sur
cette chercheur israélienne de l'armée
de l'air israélienne dans le Figaro il y
a quelques jours que je vous invite à
lire
il y avait une sorte deal qui avait été
passée entre Israël et la Russie d'abord
parce qu'il y a des liens très
très proche historiquement entre Israël
et la Russie ensuite parce que dans le
cadre de la guerre en Syrie cette
fois-ci il y a une résonance entre ces
entre ces deux guerres et bien les
en gros les deal c'était les Russes ne
filait pas d'armes aux Syriens il soit
capable
d'empêcher la capacité d'action
notamment aérienne des israéliens
dans la région donc ça voulait dire pas
de S300 actionné contre les Israéliens
pas de système restant comme la S400 qui
sont en Syrie mais manœuvré par les
Russes ils n'ont pas parlé par les
Syriens et on échange les Israéliens
pour l'instant ont toujours refusé de
donner des armes
il y a des systèmes perfectionnés à
l'Ukraine
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir si
dans les semaines dans les mois qui
viennent cette position
israélienne pourrait pour échanger on
voit que ton anciennement le discours
israélien de vient
de plus en plus il se pro-ukrainien mais
de là ce qu'on franchisse
le cap on verra dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois c'est
en tout cas une hypothèse
sur la défense par contre sur la défense
pour l'instant elle ne repose pas donc
sur les systèmes israéliens au lieu de
dire vite elle repose et ça on tord de
l'oublier principalement encore en
premier si on des systèmes exoviétiques
bien sûr des systèmes S300 des systèmes
book et des systèmes Stella des systèmes
d'or etc
la masse encore de l'armée ukrainienne
il faut pas l'oublier ce sont des
équipements ex soviétiques le les
équipements occidentaux leur part
augmentent c'est la pointe de l'épée et
la grande masse et encore soviétique
après il y a eu un certain nombre
d'envoies
particulièrement marquants il y a eu des
canons de défense aériennes
allemands alors ça peut prêter souris on
peut penser à des canons comme temps de
la zone guerre mondiale mais en réalité
c'est très utile ce sont des canons à
haute cadence qui sont très utiles
contre les drones
là où les missiles vont être un peu
moins agiles pour les pour les drones et
puis il y a le système patriotes qui est
le système on va dire non pas à longue
portée mais à courtes et moyenne portée
des États-Unis qui notamment a été
déployés en très faible nombre pour
protéger Kiev des attaques de missiles
et de drones russes
et là ce qui s'est passé c'est que
je voudrais revenir sur un point on a
parlé de frappe particulièrement massive
des Russes contre Kiev et contre
d'autres villes ukrainiennes et quand on
regarde les chiffres on se rend compte
qu'il y a 10 20 30 missiles
donc dans ces campagnes de frappe
nocturne si en réalité beaucoup moins
qu'il y a quelques mois
encore au tout début de l'année 2023 et
surtout
allaiter à l'automne à l'automne c'est
ce moment il y a eu toutes ces frappes
contre le système énergétique
ukrainien les Russes voulaient le faire
s'effondrer d'ailleurs n'a pas marché à
ce moment là chaque une des grandes
frappes oui c'était pas 20 ou 30 mais si
les drones c'était 90 100 un peu plus de
100 donc il y a eu en réalité une
réduction du nombre des missiles et des
vecteurs russes utilisés ce qui montre
peut-être encore une pénurie mais enfin
il y a une tension croissante sur
l'approvisionnement des Russes en
missiles en revanche et nouveau c'est
l'emploi de plus en plus massif et
inexistant au début de la guerre de
missiles hypersonique donc c'est à dire
vraiment
les missiles qui sont réputés les
meilleurs au sein des forces russes
notamment
le dire très rapidement
l'hémicides hypersonique il y a deux
choses qu'il faut retenir pour ces
missiles
premièrement hypersonique c'est une
convention qui veut dire 5 fois la
vitesse du son donc c'est maxinc
et donc c'est-à-dire que c'est une
partie de ce qu'on appelle le
supersonique et c'est une c'est une
convention mais ça n'est pas suffisant
des missiles hypersoniques en réalité il
y en a depuis depuis des dizaines
d'années un missile balistique missile
intercontinental
il est hypersonique il peut aller
jusqu'à magvin ce qui est parce qu'après
c'est en cloche et voilà ce qu'il y a
c'est que ces missiles hypersonique de
très longue date justement était
missiles balistique qui avait une courbe
et une trajectoire qui était extrêmement
prévisible
c'est la gourmand en cloche ce qu'on
appelle les armes hypersoniques c'est
une deuxième condition en plus du vaccin
qui
c'est le fait que ces missiles sont
hyper manœuvres c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas une trajectoire classique et
ils peuvent changer de trajectoire avoir
des trajectoires complexes pour tromper
les défenses aériennes
voilà et c'est là où les rues depuis des
années
annoncées qu'ils avaient une longueur
d'avance sur les Américains et sur les
Occidentaux ce qui sur le papier
semblait vrai et d'ailleurs même les
Américains le reconnaissaient il y a
aussi les Chinois qui sont très en
avance en la matière donc il y avait un
certain nombre de missiles le missile
Kinja la missile aéroportée
depuis des avions et puis il y avait le
missile zircon un missile terrible
depuis des bateaux alors
il me semble je peux pas dire de bêtises
mais le tiers qu'on n'a jamais été
employé en Ukraine le Kinja a été
employé une première fois
on va dire de bêtises mais je pense
c'est au début de l'été dernier
très loin vers l'ouest de l'Ukraine
contre un dépôt de munitions les Russes
avaient
ça n'avait aucun intérêt militaire mais
c'était pour frapper les esprits une
sorte de dissuasion qu'on appelle
conventionnelle là il y a depuis
quelques semaines on voit que les Russes
sentir davantage et ce qui s'est passé
il y a maintenant un peu plus d'une
semaine c'est que les
Ukrainiens ont réussi à abattre un Kinja
et on a vu des photos il laisse supposer
à priori qu'il s'agit bien d'un Kinja et
là il y a deux jours les Ukrainiens ont
annoncé avoir détruit si King Charles 6
sur 6
les rues sont dit non mais pas vraiment
non en même temps
il semblerait quand même que le système
patriote donc là pour défendre Kef
et bien réussi à intercepter intercepter
ces missiles alors c'est un encore une
fois camouflé pour la pour la Russie on
se souvient que toutes ces armes
avait été annoncé dans le grand discours
complètement
dithyrambique de Poutine sur les
nouvelles armes russes et en 2018 bon
bah finalement les Américains semblent
capables d'intercepter ces missiles
alors après il y a des spécialistes de
ces armements qui disent oui mais
attention le Kinja d'accord il est
hypersonique mais il est pas non plus
révolutionnaire au sens
sa base puisqu'en fait c'est un dérivé
d'un missile qui est devenu depuis 30
ans lit scandeur est un missile on va
dire semi-valistique qui était tiré
depuis la Terre le moment là il était
transformé pour devenir hypersédique et
attiré depuis un avion mais c'est on
peut pas dire que le Kinja est un
missile dont dont les origines sont
inconnues
voilà après ce qui s'est passé
en revanche hier
c'est qu'on a quand même appris et
d'ailleurs les Américains l'ont reconnu
eux-mêmes qu'un des systèmes
[Musique]
à cette question sur le Figaro
inversement on a aussi les Ukrainiens
qui vont utiliser contre les Russes des
longues portées dans Shadow et Storm
Shadow est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
parler alors
Shadow c'est des missiles
tirés pareil depuis des avions
et dont la grande le grand avantage
c'est leur portée jusqu'à maintenant les
les soutiens occidentaux de l'Ukraine
ont toujours renaclé à l'idée de donner
des armes qui est vraiment une portée
importante
par les
canons enfin des lance-roquettes
multiples imars dont leur forme basique
à une portée de 70 80 km c'est pas non
plus
considérable même si on a vu les faits
qui a été très significatif sur le front
la demande ukrainienne elle portait sur
des armements qui allaient au-delà
150 200 300 voire plus et là depuis
quelques semaines même quelques mois
maintenant on voit que les Ukrainiens
commencent à recevoir des matériels avec
des supérieure le Storm Shadow missile
de croisière
aéroportée
et la première manifestation de ça alors
c'est un missile
subsonique qui est pas hypersonique mais
qui est
mais lucides de croisière quand ils sont
subsoniques en fait ils veulent
prébasser l'altitude donc ils sont
difficiles donc c'est des missiles qui
sont difficiles interceptables
extrêmement précis et donc on a vu une
première frappe de Storm Shadow à
l'arrière du dispositif russe dans la
région je veux pas dire du vététique
un grand bâtiment qui probablement
abrité du matériel ou des des troupes
militaires et donc ça ça pourrait
pousser les Russes finalement à reculer
tout leur dispositif la fois de
commandement et logistique et ça c'est
un cauchemar parce que il faut qu'il
continue à provisionner le front et que
la logistique n'a jamais été une très
grande qualité des armées soviétiques
virus donc il y a cette armement qui est
important
il y a d'autres armements dont les
Américains avaient parlé
récemment il y a le kit gdam alors c'est
tout simple c'est vous avez une bombe
donc pas déléguidé et vous la
transformer en missile et les guider
c'est une portée de 70 80 km oui je
voulais dire le missile je tombe Shadow
officiellement c'est une portée 250 km
en réalité on sait que c'est davantage
et on est plus proche des 300 400 voir
500 km d'accord donc en réalité
c'est vraiment ça ça peut avoir un
impact sur le sur le front même si
toujours on le répète les armes magiques
les fameux game changers
ça n'existe pas en soi c'est toujours
des systèmes d'armes qui sont imbriqués
les uns dans les autres mais disons
qu'il y a une il y a une tendance à
fournir aux Ukrainiens
désarmement qui vont de plus en plus
dans la profondeur du dispositif russe
et ça c'est indéniable maintenant la
question c'est jusqu'où les Occidentaux
iront-ils alors il y a on parlait un peu
diplomatie aussi il y a il y a un sommet
du G7 en ce moment
Hiroshima avec un invité surprise a
priori il peut dire ce qui devrait venir
c'était une rumeur qui courait depuis
plusieurs jours mais maintenant ça
semble bel et bien confirmé le G7 on le
rappelle c'est le grand club
occidental
on peut opposer d'une certaine manière
au G20 donc le Mondial ou aussi présent
les
les les superpuissances émergentes faut
rappeler qu'avant c'était pas le G7
c'était le G8 il y avait la Russie et le
la Russie a été exclue du G7 du G8 qui
est devenu G7 en 2014 au moment de
l'annexion de la Crimée et donc tout
l'enjeu de ce de ce
sommet diplomatique c'est les sanctions
parce qu'on faisant quand on regarde la
carte des centres c'est la carte des
pays qui appliquent les sanctions et bah
c'est une carte de l'Occident de
l'Occident au sens large c'est à dire
avec leurs alliés historiques d'Asie que
sont la Corée du Sud et le Japon et
encore même on sait que le Japon et la
Corée du Sud appliquent les sanctions
sur l'énergie
avec des avec des clauses qui fait que
c'est pas appliqué uniformément et donc
en réalité ce que les sanctions montent
depuis un an c'est que
les Russes n'ont pas réussi à contourner
complètement les sanctions loin de là
d'ailleurs ils regardaient les chiffres
macroéconomiques il y a bien une baisse
du pibérus
qui est indéniable et il y a des noises
noires à plus long terme au dessus de
l'économie mais ils ont réussi malgré
c'est indubitable à réorienter une
partie de leur fluide économique vers ce
qu'on appelle le sud global le site
global c'est donc tous ces pays non
occidentaux
comme Alain de l'Afrique du Sud la Chine
etc les bricks notamment on va les
briques c'est le principal manifestation
de ce Sud global et donc ces pays pour
certains peuvent tout à fait voter les
résolutions politiques de l'Assemblée
générale de l'ONU condamnant l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine mais derrière ils ne
vont pas
suivre les occidentaux dans leur section
parce que les sanctions économiques
sont vues vraiment ailleurs dans le
monde pas chez nous mais sont vus comme
comme l'arme impérialiste par pareil
excellence et
donc c'est extrêmement décréé et donc
pour les enjeux l'enjeu pour les
occidentaux c'est de faire bloc essayer
de de faire en sorte que la Russie
ne parviennent pas à échapper aux
sanctions on sait qu'il y a une très
grande partie du pétrole russe peut pas
être exporté vers l'Europe
qui est exporté en Inde qui est raffiné
en Inde et pour partie qui est revendu
en Europe et ça c'est pas des chiffres
négligeables les exportations
de pétrole russe vers l'Inde ont été
multiplié par 22
absolument considérable donc c'est pas
un petit phénomène d'évitement des
sanctions c'est un phénomène massif mais
qu'on a déjà vu dans des proportions
moindres avec la Corée du Nord avec
l'Iran donc là c'est l'enjeu du pardon
et sur ce sommet en particulier il y
avait un point qui est symbolique qui
est pas seulement symbolique
financièrement important quelle la vente
de diamants puisque la Russie est le
premier producteur mondial de diamant
c'est aussi le celui qui a les plus
grandes réserves de diamant
et ça en rapport à peu près 5 milliards
de dollars par an à la Russie et pour
l'instant la Belgique avait toujours
obtenu les 10 trains de sanction voté
par les élections occidentaux ne portent
pas
sur les diamants et là il semblerait que
finalement ça sera le cas après encore
une fois quel sera l'impact réel de ces
sanctions c'est à vérifier les Belges
ont déjà énormément réduit réduits leurs
dépendances au diamant russe depuis le
début du conflit et pareil il y a
toujours ce contournement c'est-à-dire
que la grande place forte aujourd'hui
pour
écouler les diamants russes c'est Dubaï
et puis c'est encore l'Inde puisque les
diamants bruts sont
retravaillés
déjà depuis très longtemps en Inde qui
est le champion mondial en la matière
donc quels seront les résultats de ces
nouvelles sanctions faut voir d'ici
quelques mois ce que ça donne alors
cette carte aussi c'est la carte des
déplacements de vos divers zelinsky
depuis le début du conflit
qui a fait justement la semaine dernière
une grande tournée européenne finalement
il peut pas s'en avance il a fait un
petit tour de robe Rome
moral et temporel du pape Berlin
évidemment
Paris ville Londres il y avait une
précédente tournée un peu avant premier
voyage à l'étranger c'était aux
États-Unis mais on voit et donc là il va
c'est pas sur la carte mais donc il va
au G7 qui se tient Hiroshima au Japon on
voit quand même que ton anciennement ces
déplacements à l'étranger
s'accélèrent et bien là c'est aussi des
enjeux dont on parlait tout à l'heure il
a besoin du soutien occidental dans la
durée
réussir il doit convaincre les
occidentaux que la contre-offensive
arriver arrive dans les prochaines
semaines aura un impact militaire
décisif sur le terrain et que même si
c'est pas
le bout du bout c'est-à-dire que
l'Ukraine va pas reprendre l'intégralité
de sa souveraineté dans ses frontières
de 1991 la malgré tout il aura il
continuera à avoir besoin du soutien des
Occidentaux non pas pour geler le
conflit mais pour continuer d'avancer
donc lui il a besoin d'un soutien dans
le long terme et c'est pour ça aussi qui
s'active diplomatiquement
et pour préparer la suite oui les avions
etc donc Londres toujours très en avance
à annoncé la semaine dernière à l'issue
de sa visite elle est essayée de créer
une sorte de coordination
internationale autour du F16
de la même façon exactement c'est le
même procédé que ce que les Allemands
avaient fait
pour les chars
et puis un autre acteur diplomatiquement
qui était qui est en Ukraine c'est la
Chine
qui joue un rôle diplomatique assez
actif maintenant dans cette guerre c'est
intéressant parce qu'il y a quelques
mois on s'inquiétait
d'une forme de bellicisme de la de la
Chine qui aurait pu devenir un soutien
actif
de la Russie il y avait des sources de
renseignements américaines qui parlaient
de livraison d'armes chinoises
à la Russie pour l'instant ça n'est pas
ce qu'on voit on voit que la Chine
amplifie
on attitude son rôle son jeu parce que
pour l'instant n'a apporté aucun fruit
de médiateur et de pacificateur
finalement là la Chine voudrait être le
pays qui par la voie de la diplomatie
sera le vainqueur de de la guerre en de
la guerre en Ukraine on en est loin les
étapes ça a été le entre guillemets plan
de paix
chinois pour l'Ukraine qui en réalité
est une succession de 12 points tout à
fait généraux tout à fait attendu et ça
n'est absolument pas le moindre début de
commencement
de plan concret
grosso modo ils appellent au respect des
frontières internationales selon la
charte de l'ONU ils critique donc ça
c'est une critique à l'égard quand même
de Moscou ils critique les sanctions
occidentales y critiquent les pays
occidentaux qui livrent des armes à
l'Ukraine c'est-à-dire que finalement
ils mettent les deux belligérants sur le
même plan
et ils appellent ainsi c'est le feu
immédiat mais autrement dit il ne
soutiennent pas les Ukrainiens dans leur
volonté de reprendre l'intégralité du
pays pour l'instant ça n'est pas du tout
à l'heure du jour et donc ce qu'on a vu
c'est qu'il y a un émissaire chinois
était envoyé la semaine dernière
à Kiev pour l'instant il en est sorti
rien de concret mais un moment
symbolique c'était le plus haut
d'unitaire chinois était venu en Ukraine
depuis le début du conflit j'ai oublié
son nom j'aurais dû le noter mais il a
il a une particularité très intéressante
il a été premier ministre il a été
ambassadeur de Chine en Russie de 2009 à
19 ou de enfin bref pendant 10 ans il a
été relativement récemment l'ambassadeur
de Chine
à Moscou est donc il connaît extrêmement
bien les dirigeants russes et donc ça
montre aussi à quel point le le la
relation
très proche qui lie aujourd'hui la Chine
et la Russie avec énormément d'ambiguïté
mais en réalité elle n'a pas du tout été
réduite ou affaiblie par la guerre en
Ukraine elle reste une réalité très
forte et
la Chine pour lui dire tout le monde ne
va pas laisser tomber la Russie elle ne
peut pas se le permettre elle n'a pas
forcément intérêt à pousser venir
Poutine jusqu'au bout
mais elle ne peut pas le laisser
perdre complètement et donc je pense
c'est une supposition mais que les
Chinois
peut-être font le pari justement d'un
conflit gelé se stabiliserait et à ce
moment-là il pourrait tenter de jouer
les faiseurs de paix alors
grande stratégie d'influence
avec l'idée que la Chine est une
puissance
pacificatrice et qui ne s'ingère pas
dans dans les histoires des autres
nations c'est évidemment la storytelling
qui est le storytelling opposé à l'idée
de l'impérialisme américain mais après
sur le bellissime de la Chine on y
croira pas forcément énormément
ne serait-ce que quand on pense à la
question de Taïwan en tout cas pour
l'instant on n'a pas vu du tout
d'éléments il faut attendre pour
l'instant le temps est celui des armes
il n'est pas encore celui la diplomatie
et le résultat en fonction des résultats
de la construction Ukraine on verra ce
qu'il en sera mais probablement dans
quelques mois effectivement on verra ça
merci beaucoup Alexis en tout cas
d'avoir été merci à vous d'avoir été
nombreux les oui c'était le nom de
l'ancêtre
chinois qui était en Ukraine ancien
ambassadeur effectivement de 2009 à 2019
donc pendant 10 ans donc il connaît
assez bien le le dossier merci à vous
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre vous
pouvez retrouver ce live bien évidemment
en replay sur Youtube et sur le site du
Figaro et moi je vous souhaite une bonne
journée sur fear alive